[Music]
thank you for gracing us with your
presence today my pleasure Benjamin it's
been a while it has been you're the
second guess we've had in three years
whoa yeah ray stop doing guests a long
time ago but then now we have this setup
we're like we should bring guests back
yeah why not why not target
yeah it's finally you we told you we had
the the water someone yeah here last
week yeah
some people thought it was a joke and
they wrote in like hey I turned it off I
thought that bit was going kind of gone
yeah what about it
well cuz we play boring cliffs on the
show sometimes yeah people are like that
was the longest boring Club yeah that's
a very cool thing
yeah when there's too many laughs we'll
be like let's bore it down a little bit
this place I'm boring in there is a long
book got a peach in valleys yeah what
were their expectations that's really my
home yeah so we had a bunch of people
that some people were I would say most
people were fascinated sucking Faso's I
I had no idea until I walked in here
that that was a real thing yeah and he
he works at patina which is a restaurant
downtown have you been there but he
created a watered menu there yeah so
when people go come on and you're like
yeah can I have you know you ordered and
he's like to drink and you go I'll just
have water he'll be like I'll be right
back
and then it's a water menu so you get to
he basically does what we were telling
you but you know like a beautiful
presentation and people start if I went
out to a restaurant out of water menu I
it depends on how high I am yeah I was
really hard to like what's going on yeah
but if I was so bad like fuck you I'm
good but if you're really high you might
be like bringing one of everything let
me try all this you try your water man
yeah
all right we have an opening clip before
we just think before we get into our
regulars this is how we open our show so
we'll play our clip and then we'll get
into it here we go around June the 21st
when a Skype when tarantulas skyping
with me a brent spiner said hey you
toran something's going on with Matthew
on his penis what what's happening with
all of my men's penises were being
attacked always lands don't bring anyone
I know what's this brother
you mean what is she talking about
rational yeah without a deal yeah never
guess that one Forest Whitaker I going
right I yeah
yeah and there's also there's something
about crazy that does something to your
you know the way you see eyes you could
tell you talking to her person you'd be
like even if she didn't say crazy penis
shit you'd be like sums up with her oh
yeah well it's the the gays it doesn't
break that's right
yeah there's no blanking yeah it's a
real indicator and Santa did those
Alijah there was a very serious malware
in the computer system at church of
Gayle and caused all the men at church
of Gail to cause them to have all sorts
of penis afflictions very painful Church
of jail I think that's her own church
Church of Gayle oh I think why does she
think it has to do with Matthew
McConaughey I don't know but she goes on
you know with the penises lasted for at
least a good week in that Jews white
from June 21st at June 28th they were
just having this ordeal with penises
because of Jesuit trigger programming on
the Church of Gayle computers they spent
a lot of time in sick bay there tonight
yeah we had him now at that point yeah
what she was right mad vagina Matthews
penis when n-word I think it's lame that
she thinks that the Jesuits are
targeting her I don't hear them there
should be Jesuits are very affable
they're fun yeah early education college
chant they like to drink they like to
party they're not really into the stuff
you know what's interesting about her if
you didn't know any better like if you
spoke a different language and you
listened to her talk
you'd be like well she seems totally
rational yeah she's sitting there calmly
she's not she's moving too much and
maybe she's an expert in white or
ancient civilization a lot of contact
and I'm assuming you know like I was
watching that Bernie Madoff movie the
new one really good with DeNiro and
Michelle Pfeiffer yes I which is called
Wizard of lives and they were just
talking about how like his greatest
skill was just people manipulating and
he had this crazy thing where he was
that's the craziest part he was already
successful he was really well off he was
a multi-millionaire and he's still you
know
designed this Ponzi scheme to extract so
much more out of people and they said
you know because his reputation was such
and he was just knew how to talk to
people I were just handing over money
man you
just in it to fuck people over like you
have a fun of screwing people a little
bit yes how I really bad super addicted
to the cast yeah there's a great
interview with him on Radio lab and it's
really interesting because they have to
interview them from jail and so when you
call someone in jail you can only talk
to them for 15 minutes huh and then you
have to wait off the phone for 15
minutes for them to come back on then
fifteen minutes again so they're
interviewing this guy needs 15 minutes
and it just cuts off at 15 minutes and
he has to wait terrible and it but he's
describing you know this waiting and
then as time went on he talks to Madoff
more and more he gets more and more
comfortable but the crazy thing about
him is the complete total lack of
empathy none is no empathy towards the
people he fucked over people that killed
themselves like there was a bunch of
people that just one guy which is really
fascinating he was worth nine billion
dollars and Bernie was telling him that
he had to give seven of it back he
called the guy up because look the jig
is up everybody knows and apparently he
he thinks or at least his rationale is
that all these people like the big high
roller guys they knew that they were
ripping people off they knew that there
was no way you could always make money
that there was always going to be
fluctuation but like even in like the
way they described it I don't really
necessarily understand finances that
much but the way they were describing it
is that in like every single move they
made this one guy wanted to make money
every single like there was never you
kidnap you couldn't ever show any losses
at all this guy would freak out he had
like again 7 billion dollars in the mix
that's insane yeah yeah he he said in an
interview that when they were like
asking him about you know you destroy
all these people lives he was like you
know what about their culpability and
all this and he's like well you know I
mean they have some responsibility and
they like you stole from them he's like
yeah but they fucking gave me the money
you know yeah his thing was like these
people these people are they're not
starving that's what it's done yeah
we're not talking about people in Africa
you know when I was talking about
starving villagers we're just talking
about people his own son killed himself
really yep is one of them kill themself
this guy killed himself though we're
talking about the nine billion dollar
guy he killed himself because you want
they wanted him to give back seven they
shall live with you fuck that yeah
that's so many people's relationship
with money there was a kid was actually
might not Jones on my drowned oh really
yeah might just took too many drugs but
there was a New York Knick I forget his
name and they were interviewing him
about you know these NBA contracts are
bananas oh it's fully guaranteed it's
one of the league's has fully guaranteed
money so now like the NFL where it's
like you have this less guaranteed the
rest of that you're not getting that
shit
so NBA whatever the you know there's
salary caps and he played out one of his
contracts and I we want to keep you but
we can't give you like top end money so
you're going to get nine million for
next year and then his first interview
with the press he was like I mean you
know it's going to be tough but I'll see
what I know how to make it happen you
can be tough to survive on that he was
like pretty much yeah I mean I have a
family and others like this perspective
man you're crazy
yeah well yeah cuz if he's going out I
mean you know I follow all these kids on
Instagram like Cameron Dallas you know
who that is
no he's like Bush the Millennial hot
shit he's like this hot 18 year old boy
and he and his friends they do this
you're gonna grace listen they don't
have talent they're just like cute boys
on Instagram and they do these meet and
greets where they meet like gaggles just
auditoriums theaters full of like tween
pre-adolescent girls and their parents
and they hug them and take like chaste
pictures and millionaires millionaire
he's on a dolce gabbana I know skillset
not but know Dallas just they follow
them on Instagram and I look at you team
boys yeah no and then yes hey to meet
the people it is fascinating so there's
a there's a Netflix show called chasing
cameras yes and I'm obsessed now the
thing is that they are spending their
money like crazy because I followed them
all in Instagram and every week it's
like here's my new Ferrari here's a new
Lamborghini I'm leasing here's the new
house I'm renting and you're like you're
not even buying I should buy that house
dude yeah equity go yeah yeah there's
r18 yeah but they're also like
they don't realize that that window of
cute girls that were being cute and the
girls like you is very limited yeah
everybody says out about Kim Kardashian
yeah I guess so right but they suck they
keep growing new ones you know what I'm
saying it's like yeah like in the
different strokes and they added like
the red haired kid to make the show
appealing again talk about the chase or
the Kardashian Kardashian so they keep
the so now Kylie's being groomed alright
I think that's what keeps it going
because I think it's all about Kim
really
yeah it's Kim even though they all about
her is a real mother mother a Kris kid
is like the matriarch of the did you
guys cover her fake ass fake ass photos
from Mexico no I think I saw some of the
oh or here's the deal they always hire
their own paparazzi and the paparazzi
pretends to just casually catch them
taking pictures but in Mexico there was
real paparazzi waiting along with their
fake paparazzi so they're fake paparazzi
takes the photos and then they edit them
they smooth out all the cellulite and
all the Foley doesn't have it I mean
yeah I mean it's normal human part of
him especially a big fat ass like that
it's made of fat but it's it's a fake
fat ass and it's super obvious in the
new pictures looking really get your
life cut that's a real one like look at
the ones on the left like where in life
would you have that's a tumor right it's
a full diaper yeah diaper it all is yeah
legs are so scrawny and then she has
this giant enormous butt so what they
would do with Photoshop we stretch out
the side to meet the ass so it doesn't
look so fucking so it's like yeah that
I've got one doctored yeah yeah doctored
ones you make it look less preposterous
right the real one it just looks like
general area gross it's like a did you
just a like that what the fuck is that
what is that are you doing your is I so
ready Rose it's so crazy but it's it's
so nuts that someone my age again wants
to do that to their body like stuffing
something in there I don't know what it
is but there's no way in nature you
would have those skinny ass legs like
that that are total unathletic legs that
the collector someone who doesn't work
like her sister yeah exactly right
there's no muscle I don't know nothing I
mean I mean she maybe works out a little
bit like we would have scrawny arms this
is not an athletic person right you have
an ass like that you should be able to
jump over the moon right right right
that's someone who could do hurdles but
she's good so do you think wait
but she looks good everywhere else these
are all Photoshop let me name there's
hard to thing it's hard to say yeah
despite everything is fake and when you
say she looks good it's like yeah she's
not fat right but but that's it
everything else is just all sorted today
yeah that's a biggest fuck yeah well I
mean that's her whole thing she's known
for ass like Jennifer Lopez has a legit
Latina ass right like that's her real
ass yeah her legs match that ass like
take a picture you go get ya Jennifer
Lopez's ass she's got those big thick
mommy sighs yeah yeah yeah smack that's
all there that's real you know you look
at that you go Oh baby
yes that's real that's a real big juicy
ass God an egg girl yeah see how her
thighs are so thick the yeah yes yeah
that's all the motion so that makes
sense yeah a hundred percent that's what
it's supposed to look like she's a
dancer Oh classy hi mom yeah yeah you're
right that's dancing all fuckin today
all her lies a week yes that's an
athlete's ass yeah that's a girl who can
yeah you do
that's a girl who can bounce around and
move and you know I mean she magic you
gotta watch Kim Kardashian dance on the
stage yeah those little spindly legs
carrying that diaper around yeah it does
look like good baby Dyson we see that
all day with our son it totally looks
like that's what an ass a big G a real
ass is supposed to look like it's not
preposterous it's just outstanding yeah
yeah I didn't know she had a butt
implant that's just something the one
that my working one I would say that's a
that's a there's there's a photo there
that has the the two of them side by
side when I first heard over right there
that's Jennifer Lopez and Kim Kardashian
the one with the white right here here
here here okay so you the one on the
left is Jennifer Lopez it has a real ass
on the right is Kim Kardashian is it
yeah when I ask obsessed of the
I know you know so much about this no
I'm doing it
no shoes yeah down the wormhole was a
very bizarre thing it is our attraction
to shapes is very bizarre to through
like like fake tears like we know
they're fake that that always astounds
me like it's not that they look like
bigger breasts they look like big fakers
yeah they're the different things you
guys like it some guy some guy would say
some guys I mean some guys meaning its
ton of guys but some guys make that
distinction like definitely not into
that yeah see but I I mean you've said
this before is that you'd prefer hungry
tits over big fakers yeah any day hungry
hungry little ones yeah need to be fed
yeah I would rather give soon fools uh
just pasta to those hungry tits then
yeah I don't like big fakers man yeah
there's something weird about them for
sure now trick I will say a really good
job of fakes like you can there are some
magicians out there yeah that create
amazing like they still look you so go
those look good yeah but I still prefer
real ones no no I just like more I think
look I got so body dysmorphia thing yeah
because when do you wear it look once
you have a baby to your tits get mushy
that's it that's just its nature so what
should i do should I host them up should
I have them reduce talked about first of
all no shit yourself in the weather that
kid and our population is going to die
off get a mom bod
quiet Jesus but it's fine but what you
know you got a surrender it's also part
of life I know it's the trade-off for
making life it's now are these real or
are these Lakers I seem excited for the
personal trainer and nutritionist I
about I'm very much into fitness and
clean and healthy body so surprisingly a
lot nutritional benefit from recent
demons some of which I'm going to read
up to now needs welcome yeah she's
brewing demon contains over 200 protein
I don't know helpful is made of wisdom
included contain calcium chloride runic
chlorine that's not good for you imagine
well in sodium it can be so fancy Wow
that a lot and shopping measure those
your kid kids on YouTube talking about
you can come yeah we should all come
well what I like about this because
we've had other come eating clips on the
show is the science that this woman is
pet toy but she's a fitness expert which
is kind of neat we don't often have
expert yeah what I mean know whatever a
fitness expert you can just say you are
yeah thanks like being out a little bit
yeah and a life coach anybody can say
that there's another kid on that sports
bra and you're like a fuckin fitness my
coach things a weird one yeah anyone can
sign up for that shit
I was watching Anthony Robbins Instagram
stories Tony Robbins is in he's in
Australia and he gets out to that with
it was a black IP song tonight's gonna
be a good night and he's out there yours
clapping this big fuckin price yeah ma
fire and he's like stomping around on
her age yeah but it's all like it's it's
like he's his energy is kind of for yeah
and he's got yes he's a little too wide
around the waist which means eating a
little too good livin it up a little too
much and so yes we're all excited we're
gonna prosper here for everybody say I
know it makes me crazy and it says out
of one of the photos I saved the photo
because I was laughing so hard I saved
it on my phone because it said Savage is
a picture of him and he's dancing around
clapping and it just says Savage I'm
like settle the fuck down buddy yeah
here where is it he uh by the way that
life coach things look Savage I thought
his Instagram story why is that Savage
it's in with his hands in his pocket
this all is dad bod relax some sovereign
I agree I like Tony Robbins a lot but
the fake energy thing if I went to his
seminar and he made me fucking stand up
and do jumping jacks every five minutes
I blow my brains out
like that sir
giant humans guys giantism or whatever
does he actually yeah I said the
pituitary gallot aurlie it was like
even the jaw
you know the facial features so he has
like a very mild form of it oh yes I'm
seeing as China probably has a part of
what his confidence is right every time
and every time you slide meeting with
the team there's enough pushback on
something goes let me show you something
that rolling carpet it's like look at
that thing
slaps that they done and it interns like
he's got a point
hold up pizza dough yeah it looks like
one of those so Cinnabon you buy at the
grocery store shelf sure right those are
good no there's no good I feel good look
how thin you are like open after I've
been working it better than Bert still I
think oh girl went right back by the way
so that that whole way read your comment
so do you think oh yeah this is where I
just write down pushy amazing you got
coming a ball it's a friend to friends
like I'm not in a relationship a friend
did this for my friend what a nice guy
well this is I would say honey I'll come
in the bowl here honestly the best ways
I stuck it out that we get all I'm just
for your sake I was feeling a lot of
guys feel that way to watch the I know
this is important I'm not into watching
people you comment no it's weird
outside of porn it's disgusting I think
in court by the way when it's like eight
dudes in a glass as far my favorite
apples you like this Alamo book part
well c'mon enough guys hey guys
shit on great Peter and it's like you
can tell the real savages in porn
who are these like ah and they like they
keep it going it's like no big deal but
you can also see in the fate that you
can read someone's oh yeah when they're
like plenty that yeah and they're like
flincher of linphea and they're ones
with make enthusiasm yeah yeah I mean
gnarly but you got to thank the ones
that are really into it like no they're
not I mean you've got to be so fucking
damaged to be like I love
a guy tank guy could you Oh mommy you
and I didn't what she's going to the
camera have 180ml quite mellow smells
like bleach oh no don't even more
benefits to drinking FINA for women
because it'll enjoy antidepressant
because it contains melatonin I can just
see the audience captain vitamins all
right oh no I just got the chills for
real oh Jesus
don't want to be a drip and Matthew yeah
surprisingly no it's not surprising
let's see if everybody is a guy who is
right what they're writing I produce
some of my own streaming videos watch
[Music]
give me a call if you ever need some
straight from the source
I hope you at least give the donor a
handjob you selfish twat I have lots of
steam when I can unload on those big
breasts
Jesus why not disable the comments I
know she said me rockin would you date
her knowing she's drunk to drink so many
come shots yeah of course yeah who cares
I just have a little bit about that yeah
I know about I dated a girl once that
she told me that when guys drink fruit
juice especially pineapple juice oh yeah
it makes your cum taste better and I was
like how many dicks do you have to suck
before you figured out yeah like that no
what's not life soon is not good okay
let's try roast beef the idea that you
you've figured that out to trial and
error like there's something really
delicious about you come today was
different what did I have look all over
my diet to do an autopsy of it to drank
some water and pineapple watch I get
some water from hungry
did you one thing I don't think you got
to see throughout there was a four-month
build-up basically to the weigh-ins
libert who is fat weigh-ins where we
were Bert Kreischer and I came on I did
see a little bit of it on Instagram and
on Twitter with the hashtag bird is fat
soft like that
you see how I mean like we had I want to
show you this this is like people would
call in or like send in videos saying
Bertus at different languages just
amazing why is that price is so far
Hubbert our Cordova looks of the best
guys that are 50 get over but Crawshaw
you are a fat ton a constant Tom Segura
might and then this was my favorite than
this was amazing people that listen to
the podcast that teach English as a
second language would use the whole fat
battle to teach English abroad in
different countries just freak you guys
out and see how popular this is 11 yeah
it went when I mean there was I remember
the first time we figured out that
anyone was listening it was back when we
were with red band so this is like 20
and our left 2011 and we were doing
shows and we put out a thing like hey
tweet this and the first time that we
saw like the next day that it was pages
of people tweeting others actually I
thought it was like a hundred people
this is this thing yeah no I mean I
didn't have any idea of it but when they
got to this thing and they're coming in
from different parts of the world and
then we did a thing of hey mommy thanks
genes where all goes or you just say
that to like the the teller and then we
started getting submissions from all
over the world all the police but elite
leave it in
yeah the squad car pulling people over
it was oh we had a cops of it he ordered
his whole like on on the job he'd used
all the inside language to order it now
keep in uniform and like it's just
bananas man yeah I like you know what I
like is the the silliness of it like the
fact that all over the world something
that's stupid
it's a shared joke yeah you know like
that's what I like stupid it's got like
hundreds of these men like hundreds of
them yeah really nice
yeah that's it strange right yes there's
no podcasting is very odd you're a
podcast by the way like I remember doing
I'm on like I think episode three or
five of your podcast Wow like somebody
sent me the thing one so they had they
had like it documented all the episode
numbers and the gear on like the one of
the first five or seven I remember was
on your couch in your office at home
yeah and you kept tell me to sit forward
yeah the house is weird yeah like couch
seems like it's a good idea but it's a
terrible idea
but I wanted to ask you kooky like I
remember you said that like you like the
Opie and Anthony model of like just
talking yeah but how did you did anyone
else have one where you're like oh
people will listen to this
like did you like were you thinking of
someone else's podcast like how did you
know anybody would listen to one I think
Adam Carolla had a podcast he had it at
damn I think he did but when he had it
it was like a radio show yeah did his
like a radio show still does right yeah
yeah well that's that's actually the
downfall now I think really yeah I think
people get they don't want hear
commercials in 15 minutes right it's not
necessary you know and I think I just
like tell Opie and Anthony had just
people come in with no structure the a
bunch of comics and just hang out and
start talking did you ever imagine like
that your podcast would be like what's
that now is crazy man it is really crazy
no there's no way I could have imagined
it I wouldn't believed it it's so nuts
no it's just canvas yeah I just thought
it was fun to do I mean and like I've
been people mention it to me all that
like when I when I'm in an airport
they'll you know they'll mention they're
like it just still happens they'll you
ever mention the way
I saw the weight loss podcast last week
and like but I haven't got one episode
got more than six million and the other
one was like close to 7 million so Craig
that's nuts downloads that is no that's
them and then there's YouTube views on
top of yeah millions on YouTube yeah how
did you even know how did you know I
mean I think I remember we heard Oh
Joe's doing a podcast what is that like
he doesn't even hear about something
well I started doing it on justin.tv
which was like this online webcasting
thing way back in the day and what we
would do is we would do it live from the
greenroom and Joey Diaz really get mad
shut that fucking thing off yeah I have
a laptop and we'd be streaming from a
laptop like from the little webcam so
we'd have a little bit this back before
laptops had webcams built in yeah so we
put a little webcam on top of there and
people would like and you were doing
that right for all this oh yeah yeah
yeah that was a long time ago yeah and
then that was probably like 2003 or some
low yeah it's really long ago yeah and
then when I got back from Colorado I was
kind of bummed out and I had to move
back to California because my wife is
pregnant and you know we couldn't live
at altitude because we were like it in
the Mount I went to that house I was so
happy up there I remember that I went to
there to that house when you were
checking it out
yeah we were doing we were doing comedy
works that's right and he drove up there
and I was like up this crazy road and
you know like a narrow mountain road and
at the very top it was like it was
beautiful counts of names well for me it
was a perfect combination like it was a
perfect balance so like these shows were
all these people and the UFC all these
people
yeah then up there just nature and quiet
I was like nah this is what I need and
you know the Allens myself out sure like
just to have enough calm so that all
this craziness sort of makes more sense
yeah yeah now so the show the podcast
obviously has gotten bigger and bigger
we've been talking about do we all know
people that like you were a well-known
guy when I met you for sure but you've
gotten considerably more famous but
you're not a crazy loon yeah how does
that work how does that work you think I
don't know what I mean like we all know
people that like can't handle
same well well I do a lot of really
difficult shit outside of comedy yeah I
think that's part of it you think well
yeah I think part of it is first of all
have zero obsession with Fame like if
all my fame went away tomorrow yeah I'd
be totally fine with it as long as I
have health and as long as I can pursue
my interests yeah I'm 100 percent fine
with it yeah I'm not really interested
in Fame I'm interested in doing a good
job yeah like I know that when people
come to see me that I have a massive
responsibility and I work hard I'm gonna
stand up and I work hard on my writing
and then have a bad set it will fuck me
up for months yeah you know and it'll
make me like batten down the hatches and
grind harder like I don't take it
lightly at all right right so that's
part of it too but that's also I do a
lot of different stuff like I do yoga I
do jujitsu I do archery I do a lot of
working out I've been running recently I
do difficult shit and in doing difficult
shit you get humbled when you're getting
your ass kicked
yeah I run them the mountains near my
house yeah it's so fucking hard man
like every time I do like I know like
that there's people that could do it way
better I know there's people in a way
better shape and I know that every time
I do it I get a little bit better so I
just keep pushing at it yeah so I just
concentrate
I just concentrate on doing difficult
things do you think of it sorry good no
I was going to say that that's probably
a way or way healthy thing of doing so
basically you're saying that I'm not
focused on my ego and making me a bigger
star more famous more famous that's
usually what people do right like I got
to grow this thing your focus is
external which i think is better as a
human being yeah I think it's definitely
better yeah I think I don't want I have
zero focus on being more famous zero
right I pass on everything like as far
as like doing talk shows again magazine
articles or interviews back I pass on
every year see yeah good calendar so do
you think maybe that these people who
don't handle it well it's that their
whole focus becomes just that like maybe
we hear about them too much like Amy
Schumer is a perfect example you hear
about her way too much like there's this
big Google story I pulled up my Google
there's a story about her breaking up
with her boyfriend
there was a story huh
broke up with a boyfriend but why the
fuck is at a store nice everything is
restored because she's probably got a
publicist the publicist wants to make
sure you get your name out there all the
time guess what people get fucking sick
of hearing all yeah it is so if people
want answers people sick of hearing me
too but if you don't want to hear me
yeah you don't yeah it's easy to not
hear me like you got to go looking for
me to hear me I think the more you put
yourself out there especially today with
you know it's this is we're not talking
about the 1990s like with social media
it's so easy to get the word out for all
the different things that you want to do
that there's no need to do all that
other stuff yeah and if you start doing
all that other stuff mean you can gain a
few new fans but you also get annoying
yeah you know we all know we all know
people that are just overexposed yeah
you know who taught me that Daniel Tosh
I was about to bring him up I was about
to bring it last yeah and he has that
thing he doesn't do talk shows he's the
best we talked about it yeah at the
improv and he made total sense with me
and it really really like cranked home
you know real like wow yeah he's like
yeah ideals I don't do anything you
think sorry good no he's just like
usually I'm already famous enough right
yeah and he goes because I'm doing an
hour a week on a television show tonight
they're like they get to see me like
sound on TV so I don't need to do more
yeah than that like there's millions of
viewers watching this thing and also I
guess it was thinking being those who
like me are already engaged with me what
am i annoying the rest of the world yeah
you're not into it
well my podcast built up 100% from
someone telling other people right
hundred percent I didn't do anything to
promote it I've never done anything I've
never done that's bananas yeah I had one
big bump on Rolling Stone did a story on
me and that was one of the most
uncomfortable weeks that guy followed me
around and hanging out and staring at me
and writing things down
yeah like weird but that did give him a
bump though yeah it was a bump for sure
that gave me a bump but all the other
bumps are just it just it was a gradual
slow yeah sort of escalation until about
maybe two years ago and then it just
started really ramping up like
ridiculously yeah many millions more per
month every month millions more and it
started getting scary we
referred to like I'll talk to other
people about it to about your model of I
feel like it's definitely one of like
your ideas just hit them with content in
other words yeah just put stuff out
there all the time because that's like
every week I mean I'll just be on
Instagram and I'll see you're like just
yet a physicist on and you have a
comedian on then you have a fucking
hunter on and I'm just like well I'm
just putting stuff out there and then
whatever you want consume it but it's
also honestly it's selfish because these
are all just people that I want to talk
yeah so if I Lawrence Krauss in the
studio who's a theoretical physicist I
have questions I want to ask him about
the you know the birth of the universe
yeah but what he thinks the the
boundaries of infinity are and all these
different in fascinating people so I
have these one-on-one conversations with
no interruptions for three hours yeah
with someone who you'd never get a
chance to do that in real life as if you
were at a dinner table with them they
would get up to go to the bathroom they
check their phone other people would
chime in someone else would come over
with your own conversation just you and
them alone in a room just staring at
each other and you get you get an
education through that I've got I become
a much better conversationalist I think
I understand people better I get I
understand motives better I understand
interaction better I understand ego I
understand I all kinds of weird stuff
you pick up it's like data chunking you
know you just sort of recognize patterns
and people yeah applying them I just
have a much better understanding of
myself and of people in and of being a
good conversationalist yeah you've got
you're definitely highly skilled at it
now I mean not that you weren't before
but I mean I think it's obvious like
that's a skill you develop because you
work on it all the time
what's crazy because I never thought it
was a skill yeah I never before I
started doing podcast I would never
thought being a conversationalist is a
skill yeah I would have thought yeah you
just talk to people you know I notice it
more like if somebody that does podcasts
a lot when I watch especially if I watch
a television interview I can tell or I
listen in the bug on the radio I can
hear that oh this host is a giver like a
gracious host
letting his subject you know say what
you have to say and I can also feel like
oh the host is trying to dominate yeah
you take up on it and
this he's making it about himself all
the time that is an issue with people
yeah like sometimes someone will
interrupt a really good story and take a
sidetrack
where they talk about them settling they
have an opportunity to talk about
themselves but you're in the middle of a
story
O'Brien you've done this yeah now and it
just becomes a real problem yeah yes a
lack of awareness and a clumsiness can
really sabotage and throw a monkey
wrench into the gears of a conversation
yeah and it makes it real awkward cuz
the other person's aware of it and
they're trying to be gracious and get
through it and then you know it's just
when someone else is talking when two
people are having a conversation and
someone else is just kind of like clunky
like it affects the way you're able to
communicate so like as a host of a
podcast we're having a conversation with
someone part of the skill of it is like
trying to figure out how to get that
person the most comfortable and the most
relaxed and then the most like asked the
questions with enough economy of words
to get them to express themselves the
cleanest right that's why I don't like
participating in or listening to
podcasts with too many mic yeah I like
on them they get rowers yeah they get
right it's too much and and and usually
what happens is at least for me as a
listener of one of them I'll be like
every interesting point that I was
looking for like I can hear coming gets
derailed young like taking them like
well gives me anxiety even watching CNN
sometimes oh yeah but and there's like
six people on there yeah oh my gosh when
I hear one one person do always honor
all this he's been given too much - Anna
does like nine sometimes yes
too many ekend they're all so they're
all just like trying to get their
soundbite in you know obvious I was
watching something on Trump the other
day it was just fucking gross what do
you think about that well this whole
current state of things of come it's
what happens when you get a guy who does
not understand what being president is
and is used to running businesses and
then all of a sudden you let him run the
president's and he's trying to run it
like a business yeah it was firing
people that he doesn't agree with like
yeah I didn't know that the president
could just fire the FBI chief like that
yeah
I didn't know it either but like when he
fired call me and yeah like the guys are
he's a real pain in my ass this
investigation like that why I get so
obviously obstruction of justice I think
he has like an obvious really
wide-ranging liberties when it comes to
hiring and firing as praising yeah and I
didn't know about that I doubt until
this happened yeah well cuz most people
have the good sense not to do things
like that because it looks bad as well
be suspicious people forget though the
clinton did the same thing clinton fired
the head of the FBI as well and he fired
him in the middle of an investigation I
forget what the investigation was I
forget what the circumstances were but
it wasn't as egregious but it was pretty
similar this feels like I mean at least
from the outside it does feel like you
know every day it feels like this is
heating up into some like major scandal
who knows because evidence-wise I know
it's always pointed out that we don't
have any you know smoking gun yet but it
does feel like it's cooking up into
something you know I don't know I think
everybody wants it to that has that
sense - it's either here's a question
like what's inappropriate and what's
illegal and I think a lot of it's been
inappropriate but how much of it is
illegal true like sam harris has a
podcast where he had these uh political
experts on talking about what trump did
when he had those Russians over the
White House and he gave them top-secret
classified information about Isis
wanting to use laptops to blow planes up
yeah and he's like hey you know when you
do that you've compromised all these
people that were embedded in Isis yeah
that we're telling that the government
about this plan that they have sure now
they have to get these people out and
hope these people don't get assassinated
like you can't like in thinking and him
thinking that he's sharing information
like you know what you're not secret
yeah like what you're doing is you're
exposing sources and it's and you know
it's obvious to that like he's the type
of guy that loves having that share a
secret moment like I'm sure he was like
yeah say something well that's the whole
thing with Comey like you know like you
wanted to hug them yeah you want to say
look I hope you can let this go yeah
he's like telling someone to let go a
criminal investigation cremains it being
compromised by Russia yeah and
apparently were warned that that Flynn
guy was he was compromised by Russia
before he even got an Ave they were they
was worn books by the Obama
administration and then when when Yates
came over the the Deputy Attorney
General and warned Trump's lawyer about
it they still didn't act for another
week or two she was a gangster and those
fucking here yes she was she was so good
she because she did they were trying to
chip away at her yeah and she was like
look what I'm going up yeah got
schooling them on the Constitution
schooling them on Law School in them on
ethics and about her responsibility to
the American people like now I'm not
going to institute a travel ban on
Muslims yeah your fucking mind
yeah I didn't do that this is a country
of immigrants you wanted me to do a
travel ban so extending it yeah you know
it is like he's like a murderer and you
know and they all get caught because
they brag about shit
like he couldn't help himself talking
about Isis probably like I got something
good I got a share a brag about the shit
I love now all the reports about how
they go it's really difficult because of
his short attention span
and he has a tendency to be easily
distracted
he's like visual aids - okay you if you
talk about something you have to show
pictures to him like he wakes up and
winds down with cable news and he brags
that I don't read he's like don't like
reading not a realist you know another
thing is hilarious who want to talk
about the shows that he watches they're
number one because everyone knows I'm
watching oh right him saying that
everyone knows that he's watching these
FoxNews chefs fine it's it's hilarious
that he believes that that's why they're
number one but we've never had a
president like imagine if Obama did that
Obama said well the reason why this
shows number one is because I watch it
yeah everyone knows that I'm amazing
yeah hey what everyone loves Obama yeah
he loves Obama yeah I love him always
nothing good yeah I was talking about
Kanye Kanye loves Trump he loves Trump
yeah you know everyone was come but the
fact that he talks about himself like
he's fucking Roy Jones jr. yeah Jones is
in his prime yeah and Roy Jones didn't
mean he was the baddest motherfucker on
the planet he was talking about it in
his prime it was a way to establish that
he was it means a psychological thing
yeah
like when Roy Jones jr. gets out there
Roy Jones jr. gonna take care of
business yes you know Edwards like okay
yeah yeah it would be like a separate
power almost right yeah I got talking
about this other aspect of myself yeah
he was talking about like this this
superhuman force yeah that was Roy Jones
do you know what targets on stage I got
to go rock the house Compton girl box
the motherfucker yeah I wonder how many
presidents in the past were this
psychotic but because of Twitter maybe
but maybe it's because of things like
Twitter that we now see inside I mean
what if Nixon was just batshit crazy too
but because a limited act you ever
seeing that elio Nixon tapes that's
great what they play the actual team now
I it's really great
well he had a drunken moment with a it's
a famous drunken moment with a reporter
where he was talking about how he has
the power to just go into a room and
make the decision to kill six million
people with a nuclear bomb and that you
know that that hangs over him yeah
apparently he was intoxicated when he
was talking about this this this nuclear
option power that's another very
terrifying thing president and Crenna
the president really does have
legitimate power to to wipe out to wipe
out him to use nukes I mean he has a lot
more power than we thought they did
because there's so much restraint yeah
showed by Clinton even by Bush believe
it or not yeah like Bush's even
criticized the Trump administration
which is crazy
yeah yes no choice I mean bushings like
fucking like a like a liberal Daisy
right compared so reasonable einstein
compared you well the supreme court when
the supreme court ruled against one of
trumps things and Trump's like a see in
court you know whereas they dude that
was court yeah okay that was the best a
premium course man but like Bush they
showed this clip of Bush losing a
similar ruling to the supreme supreme
court yeah and his reaction to it was so
reasonable yeah it was like well we have
to respect the court in the court's
decision and this is just the way it is
and yeah although I'm disappointed I
understand that they're doing their best
in light a big part of it I do think
you're right though is the lack of
Twitter restraint because nobody would
ever act like that I know they had sort
later there was an article that said
they had an intervention last week
yeah they're like you're making it
harder for yourself and there and they
were like and they showed him with
visual aids like when you tweeted this
and then this was the pushback and these
were the articles written afterwards
like you got a fucking stop no it's
hilarious
it is I who knows it's good in that we
need to know that this is a stupid
fucking position that no one should
really have right no once you really
have the ability to just be the top
chimp over 300 plus million people it's
crazy to give anybody that power there's
no reason to unless you raise a
philosopher king yeah even if
philosopher king is subject to that you
mean if he has an ego and if he's a
human being he is the same possibility
of going out of their fucking minds just
it's just too much what why risk it it's
just there should be way more checks and
balances employees yeah we have to be
nutty to even want to be President of
course I think it's an absurd job
they're all they're all megalomania yeah
no way man bleep at night who knows
could be next maybe Glen moon hi Glen
moon officially announced my candidacy
Armed Forces commander-in-chief office
president United States of America if
elected I will serve holy will of God
and name Jesus Christ and power holy
spirit from God a name Jesus Christ both
moan USA president 2012 November oh he
didn't make it honey
I don't usually come back man email
person self-described 18 year old former
student Franklin or Churchill high
school I met earlier this year 2011
library Livonia if anyone knows Amy whom
I last saw entering her friend's house
on Six Mile Road service drive Webster
farm to road after I drove her there and
my motor vehicle from library I would
appreciate you giving her my facebook
address URL I could use some help
securing 18 to 20 year old vote Wow
yeah well he's doing the sign across one
he did not have yeah that helps yes Ben
residence there's some loons I have you
know what do you do with those shoot
them in a hat or let them live I think
you got to let them live until they
until they show up at the address yeah
we have to keep them in containment
though that's a problem Reagan let them
loose and we need to re get real and in
a little bit there needs to be a park
yeah what have Reagan if you lowered the
far-right UD institutionalized
the mentally ill so unleash them on the
street and it crazy because he's a guy
got shot by a man only a little pricey
yeah right out now yeah how in these out
now he has a like some type of super but
he's out but he has like supervised he
has to go
I think to it's his mother's house or
something and but he's yeah he's not in
a prison yeah so weird how old is he
though he's probably in the 60s oh yeah
I can still kill yeah oh yeah I'm for
sure yeah it's a it's a bad job and it's
not it's not a smart job it was a job
that made sense back when we were
dealing with Kings and we said well
let's have an elected representative
instead of a king so it was a superior
alternative then we had all these checks
and balances like representative
government having senators and
congressmen and all these different
people they were there to make decisions
for the individual states and the
individual individual states could have
their own laws and regulations and it
was it was a fairly good system for the
time but when you deal with electronic
media and our ability to gather
information instantaneously like you
know and communicate information like
there's no reason why we shouldn't be
able to vote online no no none we should
all be able to vote online I think their
education should be super easy the very
least uh you know all these I didn't
know but all these all these European
countries do weekend voting for national
elections and it ups their turnouts I
like yeah that's a claim for sale yeah
that's a great idea as well there's a
lot of data a election yeah they don't
want that go right they literally don't
want any more participation because
first of all one of the things you're
seeing with Trump that's really
disturbing is you're seeing the rise of
the asshole class yeah like there are a
lot of assholes out there that we're
never represented and they don't
necessarily agree with his politics but
they have like an identity thing now
it's it's more like they're in a group
of like-minded people than it is even
it's like a political party it's like a
cult
it's a douchebag cult yeah I know you're
talking about see them on TV legit like
there's a lot of people that are
enjoying this because the they're on
team yeah and it's like whether they're
rooting for the fucking dolphins or
they're rooting for Trump it's
kind of the same thing they identify
with a clan right this clan of people
are Trump supporters right-wingers
whatever they're doing but it's did they
just happen to be Trump supporters and D
hangers they could be anything else it's
just people love to be in a support
group of like-minded Souls yeah but it
agreed to a certain thing I don't think
they also like I noticed during the
campaigns it was it seemed like it was a
lot more just fuck the other team yeah
kind of thing it wasn't like about like
he makes sense on these points and that
was just like fuck you guys could you
imagine if Hillary got in the office and
was doing all the same things that Trump
has done as far as like giving away
classified information to Russia
compromising sources and firing the head
of the FBI because he was investigating
her but you lock her up lock her up lock
her up all that was like a big chant
during the campaign remember yeah yeah
well he's done shit way worse yeah why
worse or more why worse or yes he's got
my word for that brother from cliff oh
now that Japanese gypsies yeah they're
like they're total white trash people
and she's just fighting with some other
woman she's like okay shit just got why
works her you know you know what else is
interesting um that I was listening to
the Sam Harris podcast they were talking
about I like that the runs are good yeah
he's amazing the real the real
interesting issue is the ebb and flow of
support and that if the pro Trump media
unitedly turned on him because there was
some speculations they were upset the
Trump was doing some things some
intervention things in foreign countries
and mingling meddling and other affairs
that they didn't want they wanted more
of a separatist sort of like the United
States can take care of itself and fuck
all those other countries but when we
started bombing Syria we dropped the
Moab bomb and all this different stuff
there's a lot of people that express
some like there's some discontent well
yeah this is not what we want it's not
only sign up right yeah if it turns and
they United as a united front turn on
Trump the very people that support them
which by the way could absolutely happen
for your when you're a guy who like you
mobilizes those armies those armies of
assholes
there's their subject to turn you
especially if you're clearly an asshole
yourself sure if he does enough asshole
ish things and then one day they just
decide to turn on him they were talking
about this like this could be
catastrophic sheriff for his campaign
yeah like it literally could the very
people that put him in office this same
group if they have someone who
represents them better whether it's a
Ron Paul or someone else someone who
they can get with philosophically but
they don't think like what for whatever
reason they just decide they don't like
them any ax which can easily happen
totally well it can happen T because I
don't think Trump really believes all
the crap that he was saying that he was
behind like do you really think he's
anti-abortion like how many abortions
does that motherfucker probably paid for
himself you know I mean like he's not
about all the stuff that do you really
believe in I think he I think you know I
know what he's a he's a great user given
credit for being the super talented self
promoter many people challenge
galvanizing that telling things in the
moment yeah I don't think he blues y'all
even I know that he's definitely lost at
least a segment of people this past week
with having his first foreign trip to
Saudi Arabia there's a lot of people
that were I mean I'm talking about like
very very hardcore you know far right
people that were upset that like what
are you doing going there and your first
foreign trip you should be having them
pay us back for 9/11 you should you know
why are you basically mingling with them
negotiating an arms deal I mean it's
just there's going to be things that pop
up every week that people will you know
get upset about have you seen a picture
Trump and that Saudi Arabian guy and
some other dude holding on to that
glowing yeah so create is that going bad
on that what is that a love a global on
globe yeah it's like show it's funny too
because he was like the anti-globalist
campaign guys yeah like America first
nationalism and then now it's like it's
a global but it's all about the world is
it with these people once they get into
office even Obama once I got into office
I became kind of a different person I
think well especially like when you're
in that first term you know you I think
everything just shifts to like I got I
gotta get that second term that's all
they care about
I mean he's that's it I think that's a
big part of it because they especially
like the one thing I will say I think I
noticed with Trump is I think at the end
of the day I don't think he cares about
anything other than winning winning the
campaign winning votes winning for him
he's a I think he's a highly highly
highly competitive guy and to him it's
just like everything is about it's a
victory whether it's this executive
order sign this is like a victory you
know the the the when the healthcare
thing went down that was considered a
loss I think that would probably was
suit like destructive to his whole
psyche and I think all he wants is to
win again have another shot at the
presidency again only because it means
he won not because he really cares about
being president I think he just wants to
win then yeah it could be yeah I'm
enjoying the campaign at like the sorry
the coverage of Melania hating him like
there's there's a range of like he tries
to hold her hand and she swats it away
and shit like that and yeah I think you
know there's a lot I read they reach
obviously for anything right like if
you're pressing is like the level of
scrutiny on everything it's like they
were holding hands and then they let go
and they're like she swatted it anyway
yeah they want there is a great animated
gif though where he looks over at her
that smiling then he turns away gee like
yeah she's like that's that the
inauguration yeah that's amazing it's
weird
it is weird what do you like as I read
so clearly too it's like you can say a
lot of these things are but that seems
so much to see like well that seems
legit and also the fact that she doesn't
live there yeah well fuck would you want
to she just you know that's not what she
signed up for you know what she signed
up for she signed up for some BJ's and
some scrilla yeah you know saying some
Fendi bag it's absolutely right that's
right drinking your TSP a day and then
what's dick can you start right let me
think about it's a great gig yeah he's
probably only a horny a couple days a
week old
yeah 75 or something time yeah you only
probably get it up if you do even with
Viagra yeah we only wants pussy a few
days a week yeah and then the rest of
days a week she's driving Rolls Royces
are New York yeah
my gromp so he's right here right and
like so he's going to turn back smile
big smile right yeah but you forget
she's my tribe this is actually the
coldness of the Eastern Bloc er as well
like my stepmother had a little of that
a little a lot yeah yeah so do you think
it's also like part of the reason why
she accepted this position life in the
first place it's like there's like a
like a pragmatism like a cold pragmatism
with this is a good move
of course yeah well she was a hot chick
right she's like I'm not at all so
that's what you got to do it's you know
you can't model forever pictures of her
and lesbian sort of photoshoot type
thing another suited model yes as you
did some nude modeling hot looking lady
yeah nudie pics of our first lady that's
crazy that's crazy
I crazy if there was like pothole pics
yeah she liked it spread them shout out
looks like a string of spit yeah a
finger and we're back to your mind
I got serious for a minute but we got
back to the important stuff quick oh
yeah we're living into one of the
weirdest times ever in human history is
yeah cuz it's total uncharted territory
yeah it was that Miss Glasson
just classroom dude that's become in the
hunting community
yeah it's become a giant punch line it
is all over I guess ain't you that meat
eater neither yeah they said we're going
to beat you guys to the punch line and
they said it there's a glass and yeah
yeah today it's a beautiful photo there
look overlooking yeah incredible
landscape and everybody just say just
glass and you know that like when that
satifying you know we have all these
like little inside jokes that one went
like Bonanza crazy haywire it went
haywire you know people brought
binoculars to my shows in New York this
is why this is why I came up here I
would sleep in long there's been huge
metal that's a big amount all metal we
could slip along
miss Glasson just classic class also I
had been on my Doubtfire
and this also opened up a whole new
world for us which was the excitement of
a dad boner like when a dad gets really
excited about dad enthusiasm not any
other kind they didn't comment as well
yeah because usually for something that
nobody would get that excited about
except for that well you know he's a
very famous bar and I claimed I figured
that out before emailing that's like
that's not good friend I did not tell
you I told you to uh he's I watch him on
TV oh yeah you just watch his show yeah
and he saw a glasses the whole look what
I've killed everything in the world with
a comp I read I read about him after
yeah he's like killed the animal kingdom
yeah he's killed Noah's Ark with yeah
turbo a recurve bow is like a
traditional old-school bow it's like
legit through this oh yeah he's one of
the best bow hunters in the world
we recognized yeah so does he know about
this I don't know I know we email yeah
we reached out my research guys how
upset and all these people are all
swearing yeah are we super nice I
remember that yeah yeah he had that one
he had a video where he goes any Spanx a
little cub bear that there's a little
bear eating out of like a dumpster by
his house and he ran up and spanked it
and got all excited about it actually
yeah he's like way out in the wilderness
I believe he lives in Colorado I think
that's it yeah glass we have ultimate
another so we we started to look for
dads that get excited about things you
know like that we consider him in that
category and like so like there's you
know what faux MERS are no foamer 's are
people to get like not getting really
into trains and they like will wait at
train stations for trains to drive by
and they fucking get really excited
called bone marrow Dan York once again
on the SNC yeah
so I'm trying coming here southbound
North Creek they get really into it in
wow that's cool
well that sounds what what oh my gosh oh
my god it sounds like an elk oh oh
1943's - Wow
psst
[Music]
Wow
oh man yeah okay Harry take that away
Wow so these guys just will wait for
trains like hours oh my Vania I'm so
excited about that train right I'm
excited
don't you kind of envy this guy's
ability to get super stoked on something
so dumb
no that guy needs to find pussy yeah
pussy fuck me again you just abandon all
those numbers you can't rattle it's ah f
four five six to nine here's the solar
matter dad certainly benign look at this
oh my god it's come yet the moon shadow
is coming it is coming early watching
from plan yeah my god here it comes look
at this I never seen it like this no
flashes oh my god here we go look at it
oh my god whoa look at that oh my god
here we go oh my god it's coming right
over a second star look at this oh my
god we're getting close getting close
he'll filter some I got Corona that is
time guys be very big diamond ring look
at that through a totality oh my God
look at that
I mean it's cool indeed that makes sense
yet maybe that's just manases feminism
that matures all look at down there
that's badass
it is VBS prereq call that's a prayer
look at that clattering look at that oh
my god but he does telling he's now
telling his pants
okay why don't you took that flight
specifically to see that you're writing
the exact guy seemed so into it so much
knowledge you can't doesn't seem like a
casual trip I think by far the craziest
one that we found we've been sent a lot
of these things is this fucking guy I'm
getting excited about something so
goddamn mundane trans-canada highway
yeah god I love this one I finally found
the last section hey okay okay
well we are in beautiful 728 this is in
fact the very place I mean this is and
it sucks unfortunately oh right yeah I
like it it makes me happy every time I
made you happy because I lack that
enthusiasm for the road like this guys
found a way to get pumped on something
so benign see my money rain decided
about I get excited about a lot of shit
but this did with this guy I see that
and I go okay I want to talk to that guy
about normal life that has got to come
up normal conversation where he falls
apart
yeah like this is my normal shit we
talked to this guy about and he's got
some weird disconnecting well I don't
like to talk about bathrooms right and
this is
sublimating all that weird yeah he's
finding the client he's bottle necking
somewhere yes and you're right about the
lack of sexual intercourse there's no
this guy's gay or any of these dad but
that's why they're dads because I'm sure
their dads like I might be a loner well
yeah I think we're labeling dad yeah you
calling them dads cuz they're older guys
yes
I'm assuming that they're they've shut
it down or their wives have shut it down
life has a very short haircut and she's
wearing culottes and sandals you know
what I mean like they're just full shut
down yeah ladies and gentlemen your
trans-canada highway this is yours
Canada it would be something that
largely what Larry if you heard bang and
you see this video dedicated all the men
the women who made this great possibly
Great Highway possible thank you and all
caps information points it's just whoa
those noises that were like oh gangbang
yeah I mean that's for a highway being
completed I almost feel like he's seen
every stretch of it right like that's
the thing this is like the completion of
ten years of traveling this fucking
highway and documenting maybe I'd like
to think of the backstory yeah would you
care for the construction was he part of
it somehow I had a guy on my podcast
Chris Cage who's walked to Appalachian
Trail you know the Appalachian Trail is
yeah it's all through the Carolinas
right yeah you start in Georgia and it
goes all the way to Maine he walked it
it's like six months of walking whoa
yeah yeah and this was like a dream like
his Jesus I don't know he had it in his
head that he wanted to do it how did he
eat that he brings out of the woodwork
you bring food you buy food along the
way you bring some food hmm I only
concern now you say you get excited you
saying that I don't get it then I have
an email from a listener I thought would
be a nice time okay dear mommy Tina I
completely understand your need for time
to have enthusiasm as my fiance is just
as chill and unexcited as Tom there is
nothing more
educating them being excited for
something and only getting a smile from
my man that just proves that you are the
personality champ personality is all
about getting excited having different
moods and responding accordingly to
other people
clearly Tom doesn't have what it takes
to be considered a champ it's all you
PS I also get farted on and treating
like treated like a sister we are
definitely in the weird territory I feel
like this only happens with couples who
are on the same playing field lots of
love Hannah thank you fans huge mistake
giving out your email address you smell
so good but they're going to get more
from Hannah now and Tana's gonna start
crying for sure I caught him farting on
my sister thinks getting weird I can't
believe you think I don't get excited by
and you sell them I mean we discover
that Tom gets excited about football but
I mean inter the seldom is there a big I
mean you've known him for years - and
excited when he goes it goes the shows
and he does a great show I do like
excited how do you express your
enthusiasm for it
like a Jerry fucking show yeah you can
tell you get pumped yeah yeah I do I get
a rush what does pump look like from Tom
Joe I like cars like excited about
coming I was getting started I saw I saw
one of his cars and I got I was used to
seeing that he had a video camera I was
like I was glowing at the thing so I
like ours by car magazines and what
that's true
okay that's true yeah yeah all the
Corvette right yeah but yeah so cool you
do look good yeah thank you there you go
you farted this morning horrendously
this morning no other last night
really buff way yeah I'm excited about
that tour you changed no I was a we made
sweet marital relations and then
afterwards we were you know whatever lay
around and he goes you know you're lucky
I go why because what held enough art
for you that whole time yeah and I go
wow what a lucky gal I and I think like
I should get credit for that I feel like
right I feel like some guys will let
that go and I was like nope like don't
do that right now
oh yeah I just settled in you know
and I was like nah don't let's go right
now that's beautiful yeah see you can
appreciate it
amazing what you're I get excited yeah
talking about this but you guys would
now would your wife be would she
consider it nice to you that you know do
you hold them in order yeah I try my
best
yeah and if I do accidentally let one go
I'd let everybody know get out of the
way yeah the way everybody clear house
yeah yeah
you got ladies around your little girls
right so yeah house for with girls yeah
oh that's right a gentleman I got the
opposites all dicks obey for take some
balls and fart but in this camp don't
you think that you get material out of
that that's probably a blessing blessing
in the skies and I I'm used to it I mean
I'm more male energy I'm not good with
you know we haven't done this during the
show you need to do this what Christina
my big announcement this means there's a
big announcement major I'm so excited
this is down that's just being poured
into a bowl that means if there's a big
news coming oh the sound cue you know
how like morning shows will have like
air horns or whatever we have chips in
the bowl chip in a bowl
what kind to those thing the potato
chips being ported it's so loud it
sounds like like yeah I thought it was
gambling chips yeah oh right not never
phone I think no I don't think there's a
distinction made it's so klinke it is
yeah I think there's a thin lake and
that's the world I see when I learned
yeah yep anyway it's big news I'm
finally shooting my hour special
when you shooting it all right here it
is the announcement can finally make it
June 24th
at the Showbox Theatre in Seattle
tickets are on thousand ranch calm and
the link is up it is active so you can
get those tickets now please mommies
let's pack it out so I can have a great
taping there's two shows seven and 9:30
bang bang in this year and the great
city of meat rattle I can't wait to go
there was so many mommies they're gonna
be awesome and I'm and very happy for
you thanks I have Seattle's on the short
list of places I would live outside of
LA as yes
same as me I like they're very I'll get
through the winter I just go to Hawaii a
couple of times or some get through that
fucking rainy bullshit yeah they're here
so once you get through that I think
like intellectually I think it's one of
the best cities like people they're not
pretentious they're but they're smart
there's no showbiz influence yes I think
is one of the things that fucks us up
here yeah is the desire for fame like
it's a there's a total absence of that
up there you see way less fake yep fake
tits fake lips fake ass yes people only
whistle it was like people it's a really
cool City I am I didn't realize you know
sometimes you just see like one thing in
a theatre and so you you don't know if
you've been there before I did the more
and I didn't realize until afterwards
when I went to the lobby that I'd been
there with you because allow ya did out
to me I didn't really have been here
before in Seattle hi I did it a couple
weeks ago and as we were in there
they'll you've been he was like never
been here before and then we got to
lobby I was like I have been here before
because I'm ever doing like a meet and
greet with you with uh yeah we've done
so many places do I forget or get them
all yeah I'll get they blend in but
Seattle I mean every time I've gone
there I've had samos fun shows fabric
yeah that's why I chose that city I mean
I you know la is obviously my heart yeah
although well what you think the the
showbiz element that is the problems
it's the problem there's not just a
showbiz element but the problem you were
talking about what's out Instagram kids
and the Kardashians they're not
necessarily even showbiz they're like at
the attention in district the attention
industry yeah it's like there's so much
fake bullshit and so much like flossy
sense crazy yeah I mean I feel like
Seattle is bases Microsoft and Amazon
and there's a lot of tech money there
and a lot of really smart people yeah
and it's also super green and I feel
like being next to the ocean and super
green like seeing a lot of green
mountains yeah is something about that's
just better for you yes definitely so
too for your brain is a very like kind
of showy
town you know that we live in it's like
a very like show off thing I think one
of the funny things is like the idea
like that you think you have money in
this town like people who are trying to
come across that way and then you go to
a town like Seattle we're like now those
those 22 people are at billionaires yeah
and then they're not even trying to show
you yeah they were they're wearing like
a sweater yeah yeah you're like that
Bill Gates dressed like a fucking neck
area yeah baby show you that yeah yes
it's odd right it is uh what are you
doing with all that money he but he does
a lot of humanitarian tons of it that's
incredible what he's done and he got a
lot of other super wealthy people to
donate their money a lot of them yeah
like they do that to pledge well how
about Warren Buffett he's giving it all
that in the through gates he got it
through gates
yeah he's interesting cat like he's
literally when he dies he will die and
leave it all to charity
yeah so that's and he's been giving a
lot some of those guys they've been
giving billions as they're alive even
yeah yeah Warren Buffett also lives in
like the same house that he bought like
third Omaha Nebraska it's a super normal
house yeah you drove the same car for
like 20 years
oh I have all that money to understand
its aren't you fucking flossing he's in
a ball on the web but his level you
should definitely be falling slightly a
little bit if he married the same lady I
think you boring you got the wrong yeah
she got like 1.5 billion which to him
was like goblet get outta here nagging
at me yeah take a little 1 billion 12
billion dot man yeah yeah he's still
doing pretty well
now Jude or kitties that's a great city
too yeah I love you dork today
yeah that's what we call it on a cow
yeah that's a place that I would
consider living okay living in New York
City not in the winter months
yeah it doesn't bother me that much Wow
I I think it's all about one thing is
like in LA after a while even though
compared to most of the country
lifestyle you know cost of living is
much higher it's still significantly
different than New York and like I would
only go there if I could definitely live
at least pretty comfortably you know I
mean I got fucking baller yeah yeah oh
yeah you don't struggle in New York yeah
my wife once she's talked about moving
there that's like one place where she
said she would go like if you want to go
there I'll go there really yeah I just I
think she just thinks it's like a big
glamour shopping trip though yeah well
she looks at it hey babe yeah well she's
right what I mean like the incredible
alcohol I couldn't take the other cold
rough oh my god shit you know you just
dress warm
it's not that difficult so you've been
doing like eight spot tonight I know
that you yeah maybe but not I don't like
that many spots as much as I like longer
spots right I think longer spots like
too long spotted tick to one half our
spots over 850 and angry because as far
like developing material I think it's
really important to to stretch out a
little bit because you're creating like
you've composing something you putting
something together a peak in a valley
and yeah you know Diaz and I had a
conversation about that yesterday's like
I got to go to more places where I could
work an hour he goes because sometimes
I'm home for a month I don't go on the
road I don't do an hour set and I got to
go do an hour set true I got a piece it
all together like that make sense
I don't like the short spots and
especially if you if you're touring a
lot like I have been and you're doing
that long set every night yeah I don't
particularly get a thrill out of a
15-minute spot I feel like it feels like
I mean I understand it's a totally
different thing and it becomes like a
different skill set but it doesn't even
feel that rewarding because like the
benefit is like doesn't feel like it
like lines up with what I'm doing yeah
you're just getting cooking yeah yeah
you're just getting started and the
light goes on yeah all right yeah yeah
yeah I know you're saying but to me I
treat them as blocks like I have four
15-minute blocks yeah and so like like
I'm doing a set tonight I'll say okay
well I did this block last night tonight
I'll do this but that's true you know
and then one of the cool things about LA
is that I can do 3 or 4 blocks a night
like I'll do one set at the improv and
I'll do two sets of the Comedy Store I
did three set of the common store one
set of the improv on two Thursday's ago
and you had like killer ages that's yeah
well no one of one different to the same
and one was the Jeremiah Watkins around
yeah I'm doing that next month that's a
great show and we've never done it I was
the best people to yell out a subject
and then you start riffing on the
subject it's the better you yell out huh
oh yeah hats yeah yep yep and you start
talking about it and you come up with
material and punchlines you come up with
tag lines you come up with like you
might like have a section of something
that you rant about that doesn't fit
anything and then one day you have a new
bit and then you go all of them there's
that thing that I did on stay at night
Network it slides right into there I'm a
big believer in that it's not that hard
you know relatively speaking to say
something like a joke or something funny
it's much more of a challenge to come up
with an interesting topic or premise yes
you know so that's what I got that that
show sounds exciting
yeah I feel like drowning like talk
about this topic yeah premises are giant
premises are giant and a point of view
is giant and then from there I feel like
it's like that's the scaffolding that
you'll add jokes to you'll figure out a
way to make it funny and figure out a
way to just do it the right way and for
me one of the things that I started
doing really recently that really made a
big difference is I'll have a bit even
if the bits killing and I know it DySP
it's going well just developing well I
will
outside of stand-up I'll sit in front of
my computer and just write on that
subject write on it in a completely
different way and like say if I approach
it from one like say like you're talking
about going on a boat you're approaching
from this way then I'll just approach
from a completely different way and just
say okay well this is already in the can
this one's done alright I've got it
so let me just try a
to attack on it and I've come up with so
many different punch lines coming at it
from a different angle but forcing
myself to sit in front of the computer
yeah and you know I use that program
right room you ever showed you that
program blacks everything up blacks
everything out gives you green font so
it's like the matrix font yeah and I
just sit there and I can't access email
I don't get notifications nothing so
when you when you write from a different
angle will you then in your bit do the
chunk that works and then be like or
what if somebody's and then like also
and present the other angle or sometimes
it fits in sometimes I just find a way
by where that it's in yeah but it's just
it's just creating more tag lines more
tag lines more punch line so you're at
you have a new hour though right yeah
yeah yeah how long didn't take you that
long x months damn yeah that's awesome
every day impossible yeah yeah I've seen
you as yeah it's a good lesson I think
for a lot a lot of comics like you it
came out and then you didn't haven't
chilled at all on that you just like
work I've seen you I see on posts all
the time that you just like spot spot
like working working working all the
time you know I do five or six nights a
week lately at least at least four
always at least four really well like I
worked last night I took off tonight I
wear Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Friday
Saturday I got a hot date with the wife
and then I'll probably work Sunday too
and then I'll go out it again next week
and you're doing by the way congrats on
this tour because I saw it's a big time
shit man crazy it's crazy we do in the
theater at Madison Square Garden yeah
yeah homey it's all sold out not to
remain like 7,000 seats or something
some some crazy something easiest Alice
was nuts meant Alice was I just did
Dallas it was the biggest place ever
sold out that was 6,000 seats Wow it was
maniacal that crazy the energy that you
get how do you like it because it's a
total different thing from 1500 or 2000
seater it's different it's a different
thing but the energy when you get six
thousand people laughing isn't raising
yeah it's weird it's just it's a roar so
it's a different feeling yeah but you
know man I just I really like creating
stuff yeah I really like putting
together stand-up you know
and I really loved the process of
writing things down and like going over
my notes I love the process of creating
new material I love the process of
sitting in front of that laptop and
staring at the screen I love the whole
process I love the process of going on a
run and like recording a new idea that I
have in my head and then looking at the
notes that I have on my phone and then
breaking those down on paper and then
sitting in front of a laptop and then
taking these ideas smoking a joint going
onstage with it and riffing with it and
then recording it and listening to the
recording on the way home it's like the
whole process to me is is I've it's my
favorite thing to do
it really is other you know me too I
think it is like the biggest thrill I
was talking to somebody about it that
like I think the biggest thrill still of
all things is coming up with something
new and having it be you know validated
and rewarded you're like that's a bigger
thrill than anything yeah really is like
I thought of this thing I said it and
group of people reacted and then
abandoning it yeah you have to after you
do a record especially like somebody
yelled out like do the Kim Kardashian
bit the Bruce Jenner bit I'm like did I
even know how to do it anymore I
literally don't know how to do it people
under Lee Ann that only comics
understand yeah there you go I've been
doing this other thing for so long now
that I don't remember the beats of that
yeah somebody try to get I started to do
one and I was like 30% through it and I
don't know what happens next audience
yelled out the next line I was like well
there you go
you guys know oh yes even as I'm ramping
up to tape it in a month like I have to
sit down and really go through my notes
and really remember every little bump to
it and bell and whistle coz or forget
the cadence you can get away without
doing that but make no mistake about it
the more attention you spend thinking
about that material the better it'll get
most definitely yeah and I have to get
full focus like I can't fuck around with
anything like it's laser until that date
and then you know what I know it's
really kind of weird I know guys that
write on shows and they'll write sitcom
scripts and they'll write movie scripts
and then they they have like a
chalkboard they write or a whiteboard
and they're right on the whiteboard will
have no
to put like scenes different scenes but
they don't ever do that about their own
act right and and then their their their
own act they treat like you know like a
redheaded stepchild and never really
they never really have that kind of
professional focus because you don't
have to because no one's telling you to
right when it comes to like writing a
show or writing a movie deeds you have
to you have to write that because
everyone's going over bit by bit you
have writers meetings you go to the
writers room sit down people
there's no writers room or writers
meetings for stand-up but why isn't
there like why why don't we because
we're fucking lazy my discipline its
self discipline and also it's hard to
look at yourself and look and step back
and separate you from your work and
don't know that kind of sucked like that
can be better
I shouldn't list there you know what I
love the most is knowing that I'm about
to say some crazy shit like when you're
like you take the risk and you're higher
you're like oh so scare this could be
really I shouldn't say that say yeah you
get addicted to that feeling yeah I like
that like I'm going to take a leap right
here yeah this is scary yeah hopefully
they'll come with me cuz it's not just
talking about airplanes and cats and
dogs you know say some crazy shit
yeah and they and then that's quite
there's there is that risk risk is what
the is that feeling of like yeah this is
parachute okay yeah
and then the like it's you don't think
about it at the time but the knowing
that a bunch of people are getting
babysitters they're spending their money
they're coming out to see you and
there's this massive responsibility to
incite a reaction in them yeah with just
your words and thoughts the amount of
responsibility that's on you and that
it's pretty intense I've paid more
attention to it over the last year or so
that I have like ever in my life yeah
ramped it up more yeah I thought I just
think it's constantly and then my
standards always get higher too it's
like I need to I can't have a new
special that's not as good as the last
one so I feel like man I got to make
sure this one's better so I have to like
watch my old one and go what where's
there too much fluff or what is it too
much oh you did that really yeah yeah
yeah like maybe I could have cut this
down maybe I should maybe this isn't as
good as this part you know all that just
all sharpening the samurai sword
hammering that fuck
and metal down yeah I know my problem is
I'm a perfectionist so like and it's
never good enough it's never going to be
that's everybody's problem I hate it
everybody hey if anybody was any good
hates everything they do hey Andrew hi
everybody I know that loves their act is
terrible everybody ever tells me all I
knew stuff's amazing I love it Oh gross
remember we did a show when I was that
guy oh no going back and watching yeah
and I love watching yourself and like
they're always terrible there you go
yeah always the case yeah it's weird
it's always the case and they're they're
always like big self-promoters - oh god
yeah Letterman hated himself I read some
book about him years ago and every
episode he would go home and just put on
the hair shirt and flog himself like
that was the worst episode ever and in
my estimation he's the best I learned so
much but why he's the best yeah because
he had these high standards he wasn't
just half-assing it yeah yeah yeah it's
true I remember a guy one time asked me
to get him a guest spot and it's like I
went to a city and he was like I knew
him I met him before
so I talked to the manager of the club
and I was like can I get this guy I
guess but and she was like are you
bashing for him right now yeah so okay
so he goes up there just eat such a big
bag of shit so then the club manager is
like what the fuck was that and I go wow
I just I don't know so there's a second
show and I go dude that was like that
yeah he's like I know you I'll do a
totally different set on the second or
told your set and I'll make up for it I
go okay so I go let's just let him he'll
do a totally different set that was not
only does he do the same set he does it
beat him Oh name opening and so she was
looking at me like what's going on and
I'm like and I see him I go you did the
same exact thing and he was like yeah I
wasn't anything like a blackout under me
and nervous and the other thing that
stood out is that he had this is quite a
few years ago like amazing website and
like all my other stuff had incredible
you know like oh yeah yeah yeah looking
at the card like everyone he started
doing stand-up and yeah the card bought
you cards I'm over the sound barrier
thing like cards that say your name and
likes me it's like about this yeah yeah
every time I meet a guy in a town and
you want to do a guess that I'm almost
positive they suck yeah they're always
like real true say hey man I really love
to get some you know what Jess said
there's six thousand people yet yeah
you're gonna do a guess but the audacity
come on I know yeah I bet I'm sure that
though yeah bunch of guys do that I've
had I've also had guys that are like
marginal headliners and you know working
comics just show up let's just show up
at my show and asked to a guest set I'd
like to Chicago see it it looks clear
I'm not kidding yeah 37 other people hey
I like to do a guess that hey I'd like
you to go fuck yourself
yeah see crazy tell them what do you say
no I go dude this is all setup like this
guy's going to do 20 you know he's gonna
do 20 20 hands closed committed to 20
and then I'm doing an hour and 10 like
this is what it is is the show like
there's no room for your guest said I'll
just do like seven minutes no you're not
doing anything
I don't even know what you're doing yeah
I don't know what kind of wood what if
you go up on stage and you start doing
my my subject yeah
get the fuck out I just got an email
about theater not one for a theater show
there lady but here's the thing would
you ever do that never now never the
thing like we imagine showing up at a
but there's a if you were musician is a
band plan I came at just like to go home
and do a song with yes what what fuck it
fucking mind well the crazy thing about
this email to because I had this a few
times is it's an email saying hey you're
coming to this city I'd love to do a set
not only do you not know who I am
I will provide no link to anything so
you could check out like in other words
it's just sight unseen you don't know
anything about me
can I be on your show or no and can I do
like 20 minutes yeah I don't even know
you know I thought maybe like five I had
a guy show up in Atlanta and he want to
do a half hour
oh he said that yeah I said why because
uh he goes I want to do a guess hat he
goes jump talking like 30 minutes not
like an hour I remember one night I'm
walking you know Danny I gotta hustle
though you know I love doing Godfrey
he used to run the Brahe at improv and
now he like overseas I think all the
improv
yeah and one time I was in Brea and I
was thing man
I want to say I was middling this is
like probably like oh six or something
and the but I was uh I was uh I was
middling and the emcee was like I'll do
turn to him with like I'll do 20 and and
then him and then Dan goes he'll do ten
he won't do him any more like just
straight up because the guy was like
announcing I'm gonna do from the MCS
cant and one yeah he's like other 20
and then how much do you do he's like
he'll do ten not a second more
telling them like don't even have ream
about doing that yeah and people get mad
in this inevitably oh I'll get an angry
tweet or an angry Facebook message and
people will get mad thinking that you
know like you just don't appreciate
people who are trying to make it known
when you were trying to man listen I'm
telling you all the people that are out
there listening that have that mindset
no one does that
no one who's any good does that this is
not what you do you don't ever ask for
guest spots if you get to know someone
and you start working with someone and
you work with them on a regular basis
and you want to work with them somewhere
you know that's one thing like say if
you know like say if you were going to
be in town doing a wedding or something
like that like you were a friend's
getting married my daddy like dude
you're working that night and I do I
tell you want to do a set you like fuck
yeah yeah and then we would work around
it should I figure it out but it's only
because we've worked together so many
times you know each other so well like
to have someone who you don't even know
want to interject like your your show is
like a complete package like you've put
it together
right yeah you know who your opening
acts are you know what kind of material
they do totally and you're thinking
about how this whole thing is going to
play out together and you want to make
sure that audience who gets that
babysitter and goes on to me you want to
make sure that they get the best set
possible and I'm old school I guess in
the sense that I am 100 percent of the
idea that everything at any show is
absolutely all about the headliners
desires and wants yeah it's their show
like whenever I open for you and like
somebody would say like hey do you I be
like I don't know
ask him man is his fucking show like
we're all here it's called support for a
reason like we're supporting the
headlining act and I fucking hate when
they try to involve anybody else in
decision-making or how do you whether I
go it's all about whoever's name is on
the market whatever they dictate is the
way that show goes and you should
respect that you should respect what it
took for them to get to that point and
you should respect their desires at the
show so if you want to talk about
lighting or music or how much time all
it's all that person's decision so
everybody else can go fuck themselves
yeah you know what I also find the
problem that I don't I don't do I don't
take guys in the road to do crowd work
I'm going in your life it just opens up
that all hand Dora's box it forms a real
problem where when someone loves to do
crowd work and they start where you do
for a living sir I'm looking at you with
that suit on I'm imagining the salesman
and now you know that the problem you
can't think I'll start boozing and they
wanna I'm gonna get my chance he's going
to talk to me and then they start
gearing up and then the time never comes
and then you're on stage and they want
to start yelling changes the
expectations of the show yes and in
somebody who's the show is not about
them has made that decision yeah that's
what's fucked up about it
I've had that we're like holy shit one
guy did a 20-minute crowd works oh wow
really under yeah and did like I mean
this is a few years ago we got worked
into a frenzy and then you get up there
and some guys like and you're like shut
the fuck up I'm not talking to you man
and then it robble robble yeah yeah it
becomes a problem cause in the audience
mad at you huh you just get to talk do I
wanna talk I was waiting to go home
yeah yeah yeah I just want to really
miss match my openers like this back in
the day I was opening Fort Lauderdale
and they gave me this uh this guy who
was like ladies you gotta suck a dick
that's why they call it a blowjob not a
career some shit was like all like
ladies you gotta suck dick so get the
fuck out of here leave even know who I
am I don't give a shit they're not
putting good care not considering it no
no I mean now that guy would never even
vote useless being near me but I like a
guy that the club found funny and they
go
open week from there oh yeah yeah put in
from the female comic it wasn't Fort
Lauderdale oh yeah yay is there than Jim
Breuer is there a funny comic that's
ever come out of Florida if you had a if
he had a Florida yeah I didn't know that
right sure yeah cry sure he's yeah and I
Josh
Tom Ford is in Florida dammit there goes
my theory strawberries Todd berry
support now Wow but I know you're saying
in terms of like the faint there's not a
lot meant there that develop somewhere
else there's one other guy to that's
really fun to came out of Florida um
Brian Regan didn't Brian Regan come out
of Florida you might be right yes he's
from Miami yes that's right yeah there
you go yeah so my theory sucks yeah yeah
I know you're right but there's no
bastion of comedic glory like for
l'oral's not where we all go to get
really good well there's no community
right now you know apparently there was
developing one in Miami because last
time I was in Miami was a couple years
ago and I did the you know they have
that South Beach Comedy Festival right I
went with you that's right yeah and we
were after the show we were talking to
some people it's one of the local bars
and like our local comics we have like a
comedy show here and a bar here and like
we put together like a real community in
my car yeah but that didn't exist for a
while Miami was the worst improv a
history of the rock not world I had to
cancel my week I got a call like a month
before and they're like look we can't
sell tickets for a white girl we're
gonna have to pull your week and I was
like no problem a month before they knew
they're like the writing's on the wall
no went I get for this white girl my
name is big English never crazy show the
Joey Diaz used to do half Spanish shows
there Wow would you would yell out half
the punchlines would be in Spanish and
people would fall out of their fucking
chairs crying laughing we did shows
there and they were just it was
Thunderdome it we were hey oz it was
cruised I did a set there where I would
weave in and out of Spanish - and while
they write you speak full span and I
would and and it would be crushing it
pandemonium exactly would you nut and I
did one one time middling and the
headliner did 35 minutes afterwards oh
my god
you almost have to be bilingual yeah
yeah and they're like hearts out and
that give you were to ask that stuff
like are you gonna police the room they
go well I don't know about exact node
and everyone was 18 yeah the audience
was all and they gave away tickets it
was a whole papered room they told me a
story about how you know there was that
was in Coconut Grove and there's some
there's some bad parts near that in that
area like they would also tell you like
don't walk down the street from the club
right and so this one you know there's
like Haitian gang I forget the name of
it but anyways dominant in that area so
one time some guy I don't know he's
being loud or something so they go to
one of the guys is like hey could you
keep it down and then when he comes back
a second time the guy opens his jacket
it shows him he's got a gun right
waistband so the guy's like fucking from
that getting killed over the goddamn
improv you know so he goes tells the
manager the manager knows that the head
honcho of that gang is a big fan of show
it goes to shows there so and he's in
the room so they go tell the gang leader
that like hey this other guy just
flashed a gun to one of my staff and
that guy just turns in the middle of a
show to the guy who showed the gun and
was like hey no and so he got up went
out to his car put his gun in his car
came back was like sorry about this and
they're like oh my sorry about like
there's no involving anyone else and no
throwing him out well be a decent guy
put your gun all right oh Christ
yeah that room was chaos it was whatever
oh no I did it I died I've done the room
before yes go ahead it was one of the
first clubs that I said I would never go
back to I told them on stage oh you were
the dumbest fucking people I've ever
performed with him and they were howling
laughs and I go you understand I'm so
serious yeah they work like cool grey
yeah I'm like I'm not coming back yeah
yeah I remember Diaz having some choice
words about it too even Diaz yeah even
Diaz is like that's too fucking crazy
yeah still fucking crazy down there
well Fort Lauderdale was a close second
I'd say Miami was number one and your
Fort Lauderdale Hollywood improv yeah I
always had a good time there
the Seminole yeah yeah that was for me I
mean that's when I was like coming up
whatever yeah I was hard it was about
the Bluetooth everyone - blue - all
those Bluetooth I remember those guys
yeah I knew like we talking - I meant
all the talking during your set then
coming flopped then did me I thank God
there's no weird you know a Ryan Sickler
story about that and also he had a he
knew that tape for something and so Ryan
Sickler is one of my good friends very
funny comic set up and you know what
it's like when you taping us set for
something you want everything to come
together right so he sets up a camera in
the back of the Hollywood improv and
records his own set and he's up there
having a great set killing leaf stage
like I got I got my set to submit to
whatever thing he's sending it in for
comedy set or something so he's just
happy he gets back to review it and a
guy sitting next to the camera the
tripod with the camera I said like as
ryan gets on stage is like hello huh
comedy club comedy I'm at a comedy club
and throughout Ryan set you just hear
the guy on his phone call yeah saying
over and over comm comedy club I'm at a
comedy club
so that's what Ryan has a table you know
I yelling
I'm at oh no you know yeah I was a crazy
Bluetooth man that's budget Cleveland
and right though it was hiding I was see
them anymore was almost a point of it
was like a like a floss it was like
showing like you were telling people
that you had one yes wasn't about I need
to get calls all the time it was like
you see the blinking they're like I'm a
busy calling yeah I remember I go the
Cleveland Improv it was just like a sea
of Bluetooth ear pieces oh man I got to
get back and by the way that one was
that was it rough terrible Ethan seems
to have made a comeback though
Cleveland's do and I you know damper
I've had great shows in that city that
III but that Club clearly improv I
definitely had some fucking really bad
crazy shows I mean there was a guy
arrested during the show
who he sent back because it says one
pound chicken wings and he goes that one
two pound and they were like that's what
it is man he was like take me to the
kitchen and weh-weh them because I know
that's not a pound oh my god and they
have a by the way this is one of the
clubs that there's a permanent police
officer get stationed in the lobby and
so they're like no he's like I'm not
paying for it
so they just get the cop and they go hey
here's the deal and the cop goes look I
thinking like this is look man you're
they're paying for them I'm take you to
jail and the guy just goes there you go
go ahead so they arrest him Wow over an
order of chicken wings he didn't want to
pay for it Wow all this not a pound that
was good the Cleveland in problem you've
had merged stolen off your tape had
merged stolen at the Cleveland who stole
your merge these people like they're
like we want a picture and they like
totally distracted me and then when I
looked down I was like doing my own
thing then like you know I have plenty
of these is like five gone they just set
me up for a picture and then I turned
back and they were gone like wow you
know who the people were to see them
leave go after I mean it's like I turned
and I was like hey I'm telling like this
security guy like they just stole he's
like yes you know man people steal shit
yeah you're in Cleveland yeah trying to
sell CDs yeah man yeah I was such a
rough the first night I ever did the
Cleveland Improv John and a pimp I'm a
giant you know I'm saying the pimp
dancer the hooker and the John we're
getting in a fight right at the front
row and they got thrown out a midget
dude took a hooker to a show yes I found
that later I didn't know at the time and
I was just starting my son Here I am i
first time in creme just trying to
survive and I look in there they're
getting assured out I'm like what
happened I was a hooker and the John
they're in a fight that it doesn't
arrest me I said yeah I got people vomit
in my showroom on Cinco DeMayo I'm
touched
as a Cleveland problem like I
I was grinding through a rough set and
this guy and the third girl goes uh he
goes so terrible man I got like full he
is loud like it's got terrible sup man
and then some lady in the back goes your
mama should have swallowed that nut like
that meaning like this in Cleveland yeah
at the Cleveland I'm proud Wow like damn
I go you dad should have stuck around to
raise you and then like I got out of
there pretty quick it was what did she
say we need to that it was just it was
there was so much booing and ahhing and
like and swearing and then she was she
was removed so like she was allowed to
say her thing I said my thing and then
there was like fuck fuck fuck like fuck
you fuck you fuck you and then they
actually put it about what happened
after that show calm down or no yeah
they let me it was like as I'm winding
into the closing bit of the set so I was
like it was right before I shut it down
anyway like it was I was about that
close and then yeah I mean I remember I
walked pretty fast off stage though as I
got out of it but that was that was
there were some rough sets in that room
yeah Cleveland's rough yeah so but but
hilarities is pretty fucking different
that's different yeah different yeah I
mean like it's a beautiful room and like
you know I mean improv has great clubs
don't give you wrong that's like a
rougher how it's different yeah I was
there recently with Fitzsimmons
hilarities yeah I was there on a key I
flew in on Thursday night I had a show
there on Friday and Fitzsimmons err on
Thursday so I did a set on his show on
Thursday you know great the officer was
great hilarious
we started out like a week apart from
each other did you really yeah yeah
literally a week apart I just did his
podcast couple weeks ago he's a natural
like when we talk about the skill set of
conversations yeah he's really good at
what his dad was a big time radio host
yeah I know that I am the Orca yeah Wow
Greg and I did so many fucking gigs
together we should steal each other's
material well we had a deal because we
both neither one of us were really we
really should have been working you know
we were always like the many years ago
more MORE yeah like 89 88 wait how long
he's been doing it since 88
August 27th
eh shoes and we're coming up on your
anniversary yeah yeah in 19 in 2018 it
would be my 30th anniversary Wow
crazy I'm exactly half that yeah um and
anyway um so Greg and I would like would
do gigs like when we're a year in and
we'd get paid you know to go on the road
and so we had like a deal if you could
do my material to your material that's a
good idea her a really good friend yeah
so as I dude you're fucking material is
killing messages and he's like seriously
yeah yeah yeah when I would tell him on
now that bit that you do I did that in
fucking Rhode Island yeah but it was
like it was parachutes for you guys oh
yeah yeah yeah we really shouldn't have
been working we were doing comedy a
fucking year and if something went bad
it went bad
yeah you know like I never recovered
never I mean Eichenberg you know he
could have a shit joke and just bounce
back from it totally if somebody
stumbled through something he can bounce
back from it back then there was no
there's no recovery I remember opening
on a bad joke and just ridings that bad
wait long set yeah you opened that yeah
I didn't have a way to hold it back
together yeah you come out stumbling yes
never get your balance back yeah now you
open if you open bad you like I you know
is there one place where you won't work
where you want where you won't get
booked it's just like I'm not going
there
yes like where there's a Cleveland Umbra
you will do a negative sign and lamb
like I had to date a bad audience right
that does happen if you know the problem
is its same thing that happened what
Miami did with their with their club is
that they used to like announce that you
can get free tickets yeah so like number
one time going there working and I was
like check out this line is awesome it's
going to be it's going to be great and
the guy goes they're here for the free
tickets so like when you're when you
cultivate that this is free mmm it just
it you know it's a finish it'll tell you
it does but like when you just go like
though these are $5 tickets you're
making an investment in your night in
the show
yeah and that changes it and I think
Cleveland did a lot of that too a lot of
like this is free the worst thing you
could ever do to a show paper it because
then the people just start talking
okay they don't give a fuck yes mean
anything they would get up and leave in
the middle of the show yeah nothing
invest in it for me it's Connecticut
I don't go to game yeah you heard you're
told you can suck my the whole city are
jeho light the holsters are I saying
no no disrespect to anybody in
Connecticut no disrespect no disrespect
I did it like three times this year yeah
yeah yeah all those people you know you
know where you look I did Yukon I had a
great time at Yukon I did the college a
bunch of people from somewhere else yeah
but it stuck in their heads I guarantee
that they'd bust people from New York
and Boston I'd do a show there you would
never do the Foxwoods and Fox
where are you most excited about to go
on the store I like Texas well I mean I
just I like going places where it's fun
yeah something about Connecticut that's
just bleak yeah there's like a lack of
opportunity this is something bleak
about it it's it's almost like an
illegitimate state it's like a highway
between Boston New York that's really
what it is and it always feels like that
when you're there just feels weird like
there's a lot like almost like there's a
sadness that permeates the show you when
they laugh like haha I love that you
hate a place that much and yeah really
much so many bad sets there you know I
feel like I had a lot of places when the
cameras are off we can talk about them
oh well Diaz and Ari and I did a show at
Foxwoods a few years back and and I told
them before I go it was like a Monday
and a tuesday night they had a comedy
club at Foxwoods oh yeah fuck wait
comedy club and restaurant I had to put
that on my website I thought a comedy
club and restaurant they make you say
any restaurant restaurant yeah and make
you make you on the air your promos like
could you fucking say the full name oh
my god I had one there I had a bad set
so did I I'm just anyone it was great
that was the last time and I was like
never again I told you guys before this
is probably gonna suck and and I was
like I knew it was gonna suck but I
didn't know was going to so yeah yeah it
sucked
yeah it's just it's just people were
they wouldn't stop heckling they were
yelling out during re-set yelling out
there even Diaz is like we just shut the
fuck up
yeah I want to add someone thrown out of
there
and afterwards like some of the samples
like so what was going on and they're
like and another thing is that here's a
bad thing about people don't realize
about casinos that there's a losing like
this total idea that it benefits any
aspect of the casino to keep the
customer happy regardless of every other
circumstance in other words somebody is
upset at the restaurant well let's try
to make it right because they're they're
here at the casino we want them to stay
happy keep going they go to a comedy
show well whatever they're doing is
fines like no no no whatever they're
doing is not fun because this is about
the show but the the venue's point of
view is this is a gambler this is
somebody who's here that money oh yeah
we should always acquiesce to their you
know desires needs and don't don't do
anything to upset them yeah not how that
works man like this is this is our show
my favorite with the casino gig it's
always how they you know you've got the
ding ding ding ding ding the machine
sounds and I'm like what there's a
curtain that separates the comedy club
from the ding ding ding they may and you
can still hear it like they actually
have a show in Vegas at the South Point
that dirty yeah already they'd like your
you can look out and you see the casino
while you're on stage on the back of the
room there's the bar I want to find
casinos right there weird
can I ask you would you ever date your
mom definitely not first of all she's
older than me and I couldn't ball she's
my mom well why I'm your mom and you're
my son and I am falling in love with him
he says are you really I said yes I am
he said you know what
I was scared let you know too I am too
both consenting adult if if it comes
down to it you know it's just like the
gays there you know as long as they're
over 18 everything's fine you know I
mean the US wants to jail them for 18
months without fix they got arrested
they actually got arrested oh well they
should definitely arrest them there's a
fuck do you want to fuck your mom that's
our point I don't care how can't I don't
care at all I think it's at that you
want some
Mary's mom there illegalities shit yeah
got a tattoo on her face yeah they go
for it there's that go back to her
writer is definitely like relaying that
it is just like the game it's the same
it's the same but there's nothing quite
like marrying your mom it's very strange
though see them make it out ah it's her
end yeah will you ever get your mom and
all you date your son I said I'll shoot
yes I would because 19 years you're the
best thing that ever happened to me and
I really want to be with the rest of my
life as I did
don't be bag of potatoes that's you in
her face it's just like the gays or the
Betty never I ask ask them there's no K
in that scenario mom there's no doctors
that say I ask them where's it hurt like
asked him when I grant I panicked so it
so great it feels like it but I think it
is real because I read a follow-up
article the best getting arrested and
everything yeah so what do they do they
tell them you got to stop fucking the
guard it I think it's I think the
marriage partners thinking that yeah
that's true but I also feel like if
you're fucking or like you want to get
married to your mom like you just stay
inside yeah it's that they're doing this
see that's the problem with today's
society is that everybody has to be out
and proud about every stupid fucking
thing they're doing yeah what happened
to a little sense of shame keep it
inside you know it's fucking weird yeah
you know it's weird yeah it's like the
gays right yeah it's a gay it's just
like I gave it's just like the game no
they're not like oh no no no the gay
people they did you see that's it's
definitely unless you're fucking your
dad it's different yeah well that's
right
well speaking of that do your interest
fantasies haunt you do you feel guilt or
shame around them maybe you've never
allowed yourself to have them because
you think it would you would be a
terrible person if you ever went there
so it's all suppressed she went on to
say that she started to masturbate and
then thought of everyone in her family
and real
the only one that turned around was her
dad she thought about her mom and her
son and all these people in church they
didn't do any funny business dad did and
it also made me think it's just like the
gate you know real quick were you with
me when we were I did I don't know if
you were with me that time when I did
was called Jim it was open gym and we
watched that were you with me when we
watched the footage of the guy at the
carport the guy in the garage the asian
guy oh Jesus
which one wasn't what was it let me see
some of the do unit thing this footage
it's a car backing into a garage like a
mechanic shop based on wrenches face I
was playing you just look familiar no
not yet
I've seen too much yeah that's true
people asked like different I'm not
seeing a lot of laughter on Joe's day
your face I see a lot of laugh broke
that dude check out how concerned his
friends are like so happen okay look
look at how fucking cold back I still
down here Joe's laughter you know it's
not really of well with too many
injuries man injuries to me aren't funny
really
let's keep going with this thread why
aren't injuries funny generally I see
people get fucked up all the time that
guy's got broken legs broken hip like
the impact with that the cement wall and
then the toolbox and then his legs the
legs are the soft thing the legs are
gonna give that's kind of funny though
the funny about that evening the wait a
minute wait that's in half what did you
just say Joe that's not funny to me
yeah me neither because I think we have
empathize I have broken legs Kenny oh
yeah yeah he's worked this out before no
I really don't know I'm not good with
injuries really yeah I always hear many
injured here's my problem my god I've
always laughed I think it's because of
my own fear of them probably on some
level I've always had a like I remember
one time I worked construction in
Florida one summer and one of the
foreman was like I had a bathtub dropped
on my neck I started laughing so hard
like tears running down my face is he
had a bathtub dropping us and he had a
permanent morphine packs sewn into his
inside and just just drip it on his neck
I go oh Jesus I just laughed that I
couldn't stop laughing so crazy but I
mean it's not even it's not a calculated
choice to laugh it just happens that's
why
because I I actually fear it happened
yeah that maybe it's not calculated now
starts happening just started half an
earlier so yeah I can't control myself I
see so many injuries that's true
people's head get bashed in they got to
realize I've probably seen more people
fuck people up like fanatically and
fights yeah then maybe almost anybody
who's ever lived that's probably true up
close yeah I have called I mean it's
probably a few guys that are closing in
on me now numbers-wise
other commentators on fights but I've
commentated thousands of fights yeah
think about that all the different
concussions I've seen all the different
knockouts now here's the funny thing is
that I really don't I don't laugh when I
see head trauma no no it doesn't do it
to me like leg trauma yeah like yeah
screaming the screaming is like it makes
me laugh and it's pelvis being crushed
by the car hilarious
but Steve oh did show me this new guy
that he's working with Steve owes like
mentoring some young psycho yeah who's
doing a lot of like jackass styles Danza
and his kid put on speedo and rode a
skateboard off of a makeshift ramp into
a pile of cactuses it was so fucking
crazy OHS watches like oh my god like my
whole body you know that thing we get
when you see someone about to get in an
accident and like yeah ten yeah yeah
gentleman pumps to your body and like
it's almost like you feel like sharp
pointers all our skin hmm yeah that's
how I felt when I saw watch this kid
launch his body into the cactus I know
we saw one last week remember that yeah
I don't talk about anything this dude
was trying to do a jackass stunts and he
had a rope around his nutsack and tied
the other end to a tree and then ran and
jumped oh no rip his balls off yeah they
died yeah
the hit little balls anymore his not
popped out man it's this video this
don't want to when I came out look
dipshit when I came out well what did
you think was going to happen oh my god
oh my god oh my god we can even do that
you told Dad I can't even look at that
uh I can't
yeah you like that doesn't make me laugh
that's definitely streaks me out but do
you think that I mean it is like a
cliche thing to say but don't you think
that that in some ways is evolution like
that there are acted out there's dumb
people that will do dumb things and it's
almost they're supposed to die or lose
their ability mean it's it's kind of
symbolic to this guy's tying this to his
reproductive organs you're right and I
write off maybe maybe it's an
unconscious wish fulfillment like he
doesn't want to live to reproduce yes
you know Narumi what what would be best
case scenario there oh yeah it would
hurt his balls and they wouldn't rip off
yeah right right
he jumped with the rope oh my god okay
all right all right don't wanna go oh my
god oh my god Oh for you and the bar and
no I mean I wanted to talk about your
morning cards but that you know I got it
I'm mourning for as opposed to what
evening farts so different well I'm a
real I don't know if you are I wake up
with lots of noises no just all I'm a
stall working or I'm a symphony and you
find that your digestive tract and
everything is working better
excuse me working better since you're
dying 100% yes used to shit a lot worse
and now it's much better yeah you used
to have like diarrhea every day yeah I
think he's allergic to sugar or some
real I think everybody is well I have
like even now you know I'll be pretty
clean for a number of days you know even
weeks I'll be like I'm going to eat this
right
now I'll indulge in something rich and
sugar
this fucking never agrees with me Oh
kills you yeah you got used to it for a
while right yeah and now that you're not
used to it your body does know what to
do with it what is actually found that
in a lot of what times what I want is
just like a taste of something always
have a bite and I'll be like I'm
actually I used to go like I'll have 70
bites of that and now it's like one or
two kind of satisfies yeah
and then I don't feel sick it's not
xevious stuff fucking amazing dude I
love it
and yet she makes it the water guy spit
it out water yeah Martin Risa spit it
out and and I but my theory on is this
though if somebody who's like
restricting themselves from sweetness
all the time it's like an indulgence you
can have yes so it is like it's I notice
it's a lot too sweet for a lot of
people's palate but you don't know how
much sugar there regularly having it was
for me I feel like it's that click the
free cheat right so you have your Z BIA
you take sweetness again it's not it
doesn't bother me even a little I enjoy
the taste I don't anymore I feel like
it's to synthetic tasting that's what
bothers me it's like I like the dr.
pepper alike taste but I like a Lacroix
I'd rather do that oh those are great
hello Bo I think this controls are so
light yeah you know they have Z via
water where it's just a good the tiniest
hint of flavor it's more like a Lacroix
okay my dad so they have the Xevious
soda they have Z the energy drinks -
which are amazing they're really good if
you know that it's better tasting than
redbull oh yeah yeah totally
people we get a lot of song submissions
people send in songs they make do you
know like somebody made let's go water
champ that you said into a song like
they do please tell the audience so I
think I'm pretty good at that you're
impressed with my water can somebody
walk you're the water champ he's in the
water champ for as long as I've known
you
the water on the water even the water
camp propaganda let's go let's go let's
go watch out on the water on the water
let's go let's go water Jamshedji on the
water current water cancel
Tom yes it running away go pick go let's
go water channel on the water on the
water yeah right now does that bother
you
you guys are better'n me all the time
are you guys competitive with everything
just where it gets competitive with
stand-up know just where it's important
your own personality water oh that's
probably why we transfer and like water
and personality I never in life yeah
this is a real argument yeah but like
but I mean I was it was real when we
were arguing initially about who drinks
more water I thought it was because I
know I had a doctor tell me I should
stop drinking so much waters what kind
of doctor was he urologist he goes
you're drinking too much drink drink far
less yes remember she's an exaggerator I
am didn't really tell you to stop
drinking water he goes how much you
drinking and I told him he goes you
don't need to do that that's not that's
a myth he goes just drink when you're
thirsty you're over hydrating true story
can you over hydrate though you can if
you go canned I'll eat really nuts yeah
if you go like like a radio contest or
when we when we do water cut for the
weigh-ins I mean I don't know exactly
what I know I didn't feel good but I
drank over a gallon of water like during
that part of the last podcast and we
didn't have to pee it I remember that
you kept throwing down the water we
talked about it you had like nine or ten
fucking bottles with you but I mean
that's not good probably my body was
like so craving water yeah but you just
wanted to win that running away Joe that
was a horrible but the two or three days
leading up to those weigh-ins were just
horrible at our house I mean he was
taking hot baths and then going into the
jacuzzi and drinking distilled water and
then going to Burke Williams and doing
the sauna and then
I thought he was gonna die you really
did it though that was what was
impressive about this like you fucking
went for like burnt was kind of
pretending to be going for it which is
really interesting because you were
talking shit to him and I know you're
being comedic but you were also being
honest yeah you're like that's what's
called playing catch-up suckers yeah
yeah you guys want to buy into that shit
yeah yeah he was trying to catch up at
the end the words you had a sustained
effort a disciplined effort over long
period from the jump off I knew that
that would be the two ways
psychologically that we go I know yeah
from the very beginning that yeah you
had to deal with his crazy yes that was
the thing about crazy and I even talked
to him about that and I said the crazy
is going to help you I go but you're
going to need more than the crazy I go
because you're crazy is going to help
you but your body can only lose so much
weight over a short period of time right
so don't think it because Tom's not
fucking around I go he's really doing
this so like you can't just rely on
crazy yeah I know I know I know I know
I'm only drinking double Tito's and soda
and the crazy thing that is so crazy
his videos he's always so drunk yeah I
worry about him man because he's like
what 46 now or something like that how
old is it three three oh that's not blue
off no look yeah but what's great is
okay but here's the thing sage 43
you can't do that when you're 50 I agree
now agree me kind of can but you're
you're going to fall apart well you can
if you have those Mickey Mantle genes
yeah that long form DNA yeah long strand
DNA yeah you there comes a point in time
where your body is like hey man you
can't do this every day
I know it's enough he does have an
incredible stand among kanima to the
ability you know like hit I'm like I
admittedly not a party guy man like if I
have a few drinks and I'm 38 I mean I
feel it for days yeah he has that like a
he's just like what let's go out and I'm
like dude like when we when you sound
very graciously sent us to go watch the
Cavs and warriors play for for doing the
weight loss thing you know I mean we
were like drinking in the morning and I
was like I gotta go take a nap and it's
like did like how easily I'll go to the
bar see
whoa and I just you know I I took a nap
and like I mean I had to like really
pace myself by the way whatever came out
of that was re re well as I mean people
know now he's he was gone for a long
time right he finally came back from his
Vision Quest and more months four months
ought to good I'm so jealous
I know 85% of it was to avoid his debt
with you guys
yes as long as I just don't have an
email or answer phone he said that he
did a podcast where he opened up as
saying it was because Tom's tastes were
so outrageously yeah he snacks on caviar
yeah yeah so they're very funny that's
pretty who's writing about his podcast
coming back was Hitler it was very funny
and he was actually even joking around
that that was ye yeah ran he but he
called me he goes all right where do you
want to go but and I go I don't know
he's like I've gotta fucking do
something like it like I get like a
hundred tweets a day like hey yeah I saw
them already took care of it I did I
told him I got old there's no I don't
want to go on a fun but he was like oh
take you somewhere well he fucked up
when it when it happened at the time
yeah you're supposed to step up then
yeah he was trying to figure it out of
it yeah he was you know no point one
five things shorter than like I man yeah
but what was his argument the BMI he was
like he's like well BMI why you're not
actually six feet or 511 and 8/10 so
your actual BMI to get out of that had
to be if you were an inch taller or no
they said 25 pounds right dude it was
kind of write it down paper Jim I know I
know I learned my lesson
that's another crazy should he say now
I'll tell you later
oh don't come
sanim ah now all right we should we
should we should wrap this up
so there's anything else you have no
Jean thank you for coming Joe yeah well
madam we'll do this we do this run down
at the top of dates but just so you know
you go to Joe Rogan dotnet flash tour
and you doing
you better hop on it cuz you added all
these shows and those are going to go
quick yeah ii chose to like a lot of
places yeah it'd be nuts yeah here's the
song how i glass by young patreon on our
way out thanks a lot for coming man i
pleasure thanks right yeah you sounds a
ranch baby got to put this down
john country
i drowned put that down jumping tree
[Music]
just love this meadow - whipping along
to stick use metal glass now here it de
la God
football football I look at dem moves
right on his ass ain't you heard this is
hard glass oh oh
Joe's right motherfuckers play goodnight
pull back my string and set my sight and
my arrow into flight I got a really bad
boy Quentin encompass the 40 seconds of
mongers last year you never see them
we've got our and Quinn not to marry my
dad wasn't about that boy well best dad
override I never had I'm a software
apart trying to slip my dad I'm smell of
his peers the scent of this as a fuel of
the compass you know that I'm bear ain't
got no simple depth of your mind it's
just like the game when you marry your
dad you gotta be coming earth girls and
there's the progress of your mobile Ross
fa RT Thomason the crevice of your
twists a vegan banana do you know how
much money my smile is I got a really
bad bad got a really bad bite come - by
the end of the night just slipping in on
this meadow my you've been slipping
along this big huge metal glass and now
here great day of gloss football
football football I'm a good damn moves
right on his ass
ain't you heard this is how classy to
handle it in the pouch yeah did you know
you're under water simple waterfall with
a Perrier imma trick it out how you feel
about this we hit the shower get a whiff
of you kids I like my hair mice playing
alone they could shit my mouth through
the hair my car
let's go to school let's let her loose
that's right as long as let us all this
glass glass glass glass slide a moose
that's Gladys course less balls left